Gothenburg in western Sweden is one of
seven venues that will host the women's
euro 2013 it's one of the highlights of
the year for the country's
second-biggest city and residents are
already in football fever
and they're not the only ones Amanda
edgren is a 19 year old striker from the
Women's Club gothenburg FC she hopes to
one day play on the country's national
team
dish instead cancel me women's soccer is
growing more and more popular she washes
so some of the older players used to
have to work full time while they played
hierarchical that many of the younger
professional women players can now
almost live from the game so to get up
to yeah it's growing in popularity every
year then we saw that the members of the
Swedish national team are currently
quartered in this hotel not far from the
city the players have gotten used to
press conferences and cameras women's
football has really taken off in Sweden
in the last few years
Dona Paula navicula women's football is
growing in terms of both breadth and
quality professional players are getting
better and better and the media is
encouraging the sport which means more
and more girls are curious about it and
one and give it a try as BLM authorities
and this is one of the venues where
they'll be playing in the heart of the
city is the Gamla eleve stadium home for
the Swedish women's national team it's
also where volunteers come to help out
with the tournament around 1400 of them
will try to make sure the games go off
without a hitch and that's right I went
to the website because I actually wanted
to look for tickets that's where I saw
the job and now I'm working here for
three weeks now the secretary I think
look at the market you gothenburg city
center will be transformed into a fan
zone for the women's hero 2013 games
will be broadcast here live on giant
screens concerts will take place and a
beer garden looks set to do a lively
business
yet the boy out there and gents on me
we've earned a reputation as being the
football capital in swim Oh what sets we
a football and yet before you now will
be able to show that we can cope with
events of this size and by the bus on a
hard even among will be can what a man
at aquis and that we're also supporting
the development of women's soccer phenom
for outside addicted padam football on
whether in the fan zone or like here on
the lawn or Park many in Gothenburg are
looking forward to the opening match on
wednesday evening when sweden faces off
against denmark
your mom come as my husband watches the
championship so I watch with him how
come you call a pole i watch on TV
because I don't have any tickets domain
you see some lucky Leah it's a special
thing in the stadium with all the other
people the atmosphere will be incredible
goody ever i saw i still want to jersey
with the name of the swedish captain on
the back laura shaylen that was what
ever getting one shouldn't be a problem
the women 0 2013 goes until july 28 the
Swedes biggest threats are Germany in
France but win or lose the Swedes are
certain to prove fantastic hosts
you